welcome to the kill test you ready yes
sir
it'll kill
genghis khan sword sweet
one of the most notorious rulers in
history genghis khan and his mongolian
army conquered the asian continent
through terrifying land seizures
throughout the 13th century khan and his
troops used the slightly curved sword to
inflict deep and lethal attacks during
horse raids killing tens of millions of
people in their path
this brutal single-edged blade was
lightweight for sustained mounted combat
while the razor sharp edge easily
decapitated prisoners which was often
the tactic used when seizing new
territory
having established the mongol empire one
of the largest land empires to date
genghis khan remains one of the most
prolific rulers in history
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
kill test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do i will take your
sword and deliver some killing blows to
this ballistics dummy peter are you up
first you ready yes sir let's do this
[Music]
oh
[Music]
all right peter first up your edge is
sharp the balance feels good but it did
take quite a pronounced bend but the
more important thing is
it'll kill
i timed that perfectly
all right doc everett are you ready sir
let's do some surgery
[Music]
[Music]
yikes
all right everett your edge is very
sharp it slashes nicely your tip
punctures easily cuts on the way out
with all these cuts
it will kill
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test
now to test the strength and overall
construction of your blades i'll be
attacking our armored targets over here
peter you're up first you ready
let it rip tater chip
all right peter um
i'm gonna start with your handle
i find it really comfortable uh the way
it flares towards the tip works pretty
good for my hand i love what you did
with this kind of low layer count
damascus it's very dramatic
but
we've got some
very deep rolls
on this edge
there you go
here
those chips that's an issue but all
did a good job
all right everett you ready i am okay
yeah piece of armor
all right everett your blade still spot
on what i really like is the fact that
that that blade
is at its widest point maybe 3 16 of an
inch
you don't need weight
and mass for strength and a properly
tempered blade that's really good you've
got a section of blade here that's not
quite as sharp as it was right there oh
i think you did a great job awesome
all right bladesmiths this is the war
batter slice
to test the sharpness of your blade i
will take your weapon and slash across
these war banners
peter you're up first you ready yes sir
let's do this
[Music]
so where your edge has a chip you can
see it catches and rips through the
banner where it's not it cuts nicely
overall sir it's a little cut
all right everett's your turn you ready
sir i think this beats the hell out of
peer review
all right let's find out
okay everett your edge here
does cut it's sharp it cuts in some of
the areas on some parts of it it ripped
but overall sir
it'll cut awesome
all right gentlemen based on what we've
seen in the weapons test the judges have
made their final decision about which of
you is our next forest and fire champion
peter
your sword took the most damage in our
strength test you had a rolled edge and
your blade bent for that reason i have
to dismiss you from the forge i may not
be the fortune fire champion
but i still think i'm a badass smith
well everett your blade is comfortable
well balanced strong and deadly and that
makes you the forest and fire champion
and that's a title that comes with a
check for 10 grand good job come on
forward and shake our hands man
this experience was really fun it was
really tough in a lot of places and it's
been a hell of a ride
general patton's saber
[Music]
renowned for his expertise in tank
warfare during world war one and two
general george s patton of the us army
was also an exceptional swordsman and
olympic fencer his signature sword of
his own design the m1913 saber was built
based on his saber training in france
the lethal blade was known for being a
vicious thruster both on horseback where
the speed of the horse and the precision
strike of the point inflicted maximum
bodily destruction
and on foot where a soldier could use
lunges and parries to attack their
enemies
although general patton perished in
germany shortly after the second world
war his legacy lives on through his
sword's design which is now revered as a
prized artifact among collectors
welcome to the kill test your sabers
look deadly
to find it out i will take your weapon
deliver some slashes and thrusts on this
ballistic stump
john you're first you ready for this
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
cut its heart out
it's just not right
all right john first up let's talk about
the handle construction it's a little
bit on the big side but i'm able to hold
on to it
now
your edge
it's very sharp
and it is a pleasure to wield because
aside from looking beautiful
it will kill
thank you very much
all right chris your turn are you ready
sir yes sir i sure am
[Music]
[Music]
all right chris let's talk about your
saber here
first up what i love about it it's got a
sharp edge
every swing i do cuts the one thing here
is that you did pick up a little bit of
a bend right here at this junction
it's warped a little bit
but it pierces and cuts
and most importantly
it will kill
thank you sir bladesmiths your general
patent saber will kill for that you
deserve a general path on the back
next up is the strength test jay
all right bladesmiths for a strength
test i'm gonna take your sabers
and i'm going to beat them and stab them
into these field obstacles
now i'm not really concerned about what
your swords do to our obstacles i want
to see the opposite what they do to your
swords john you're first you're ready to
go ready to go all right let's do it
hmm
nice job john i like the blade
the sword itself overall is on the heavy
side the handle is a lot there a lot of
extra weight
it does help counterbalance quite a bit
though
still got a good edge on it there was
some pretty heavy strikes on there and
the blade bent but came back to true
it's all right tight and straight
good job thank you how you feeling chris
good as it can be sir all right
that right here
no cuts no blood
lucky day
chris your blade has suffered a
catastrophic failure in our strength
test and unfortunately
you cannot continue with testing which
means you cannot be the forged fire
champion
please exit the forge
well john general patton was known for
being a tough guy and you made a tough
and sharp sword they really honored his
name congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion and that's a title
that comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars good job
thank you thank you
how do you feel right now oh yeah
all right man come on over and shake our
hands
good job brother it's a beautiful sword
yeah
i'm the new forge and fire champion you
did a phenomenal job in that hatred
thank you sir i'm proud of what i did
and it's been a fun deal hey can i get a
forge and fireball buckle now
no bell buckle come on
napoleon's saber
one of history's most ingenious military
minds napoleon bonaparte was france's
emperor beginning in the early 1800s
napoleon revolutionized battlefield
tactics with the brilliant use of
cannonade in close coordination with
cavalry
his lightning-fast horsemen carried
pistols and curved sabers which
delivered deadly thrusts and crippling
slashes in close combat
in the pivotal battle of morengo a
victory that assured his political
ascendance in france napoleon carried
this gold-adorned saber
all right blaze bits to find out what
kind of lethal damage your weapon will
do i'm gonna deliver slashes and thrusts
on this big carcass
seth you're up first you ready for this
let's do it
[Music]
all right seth from the snotter to the
trotter every cut with this as you can
see offers a very
deep lacerating cut the only issue is
that your blade did pick up a little bit
of a bend but overall sir with the way
this weapon moves and feels
it will kill
thank you very much good job
all right stephen your turn you ready
sir yes sir let's do this i'm hoping
that it will kill
[Music]
[Music]
that's heavy too heavy
all right stephen let's talk about your
saber here it's a heavy unbalanced sword
the minute you pick up it wants to pull
straight down
it's hard to wield but the weight of
your sword here will definitely bash in
and cut so it will kill
thank you up next is the strength test
and we have
the jaminator jay
oh bladesmiths a saber's supposed to be
a sturdy weapon so let's see how yours
hold up on our strength test the ram
skull chop
now i'm going to take each of your
sabers
and with no mercy it all bash them into
this ram skull
it's not only gonna test the overall
strength of your knife but the heat
treat on your edge now i don't really
care what your swords do to the skulls i
want to see what the skulls do to your
swords now seth you're up first you're
ready to go swing it good
all right seth your edge held up but we
do have a bigger bend in the blade than
we had before your guard
is now
mobile and both of your bolsters came
off as well so this mechanical
connection right in here failed but the
connection between your blade and your
handle is still sturdy
you took some damage but you survived
good job thank you sir
steve i have to seeing that how you feel
i don't know let's see
there you go they had heat treatments
well steve we obviously have a problem
here you got a very coarse brain
structure in here
so i don't know if there was enough
tempering done on this 5160 blade
i mean
one strike is all it took and snapped it
right in half so that's obviously a
problem
well steve there's nothing left to test
your blade has suffered a catastrophic
failure and can no longer continue in
this competition and for that reason i
have to ask you to please exit the forge
i'm upset i'm very disappointed that the
blade broke like that i'm not coming
home as a champion but i'm coming home a
whole lot smarter i've made some friends
that i'll have forever i would do this
again no questions asked
well seth this is a competition where
the best blade wins your blade survived
this strength test you are the forest
and fire champion and that's a title
that comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars how do you feel
surreal right now well good job brother
you're a champion i could not be more
excited about this experience this
competition has been some of the most
fun of my life the money's gonna do some
things for the shop and my wife and my
daughter are gonna go on a real nice
trip good job
my name is seth boris and i'm the
forging fire champion
george washington's colismar
i've never even heard of this thing
never seen it nothing right now my heart
is just racing because i'm freaking out
the kogish mod was a unique dueling
sword that became popular during the
late 17th century and was a favorite
blade style of george washington
the weapon had an extremely broad forte
which gave the blade ample parrying
strength however the sword rapidly
tapered to a thin point allowing for
precise thrusting and stabbing attacks
an avid sword collector george
washington even had a kalish mart bladed
small sword at his side while swearing
in as america's first president the
weapon was such an iconic part of
washington's persona one can even be
spotted alongside the first president in
this iconic 1824 john trumbull painting
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do i will take your
kaleeshman deliver harassing cuts and
thrust to this big carcass
joshua first you ready not really but go
ahead
all right josh first up it's got nice
weight to it now your handle
construction it is
small enough to where i can get my hand
around it but it doesn't roll your edge
as you can see
is sharp
it will kill like sir
all right dan it's your turn you ready
for this let's do it
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right dan you have a very aggressive
tip
the thrusting worked very well
but your edges right here are not sharp
i mean i can even move it around with my
glove it's not cutting it you can see
that your blade took a bend
but overall because you're able to
thrust this blazer will kill thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test our cherrywood shop
in honor of george washington
the koshmar was known as a fast light
flexible weapon it was designed for the
dual so to test the strength of your
blade i'll be doing several tip cuts
against that wood and then thrusting
into it flexing your blade in both
directions make sure that temper's right
and that that blade doesn't pick up a
set joshua up first you ready go for it
[Applause]
[Music]
all right josh there are a lot of pointy
bits on this guard that don't need to be
there that really
digs right into your hand
then that did well it flexed very nicely
and came back to true
so good job thank you
all right dan are you ready to go sure
let's go
[Music]
uh
i commend your your effort in making a
blade that's that's very nicely uh done
but
the heat treat on this blade
has just failed
um
i mean i no longer know where the tip is
which is disappointing because i think
you did a beautiful job constructing
this weapon
all right bladesmiths to find out how
sharp your weapons are i will take a
kalish martin deliver harassing slashes
and thrust on these sandbags
joshua first you ready for this sure
all right josh once again
very sharp edge on your blade right here
easily cuts through these sandbags it
stayed true
easy to align and see my target and cut
it and
it will cut thank you
dan you ready yep let's do this
then
when i look at the band on this color
schmarr
i won't be able to stab straight and
through i won't really know where the
tip is and for me that's a real problem
i don't feel like i can test this plate
in the same way i can test the blade
before it because if i have to do any
kind of corrections that's not a fair
test
unfortunately dan your blade did not
make the cut for that reason i have to
ask you to please leave the forge
as you know like a period piece as a
wall hanger my blade was spot on but as
a sword just didn't make the cut josh
you are the new forged and fire champion
and that is a title it comes with a
check for 10 000
good job
this is hands down one of the best
moments of my life good job thank you to
like my wife and my kids this just
proves that you can do anything it's
just a matter of putting your mind to it
and putting your heart
[Music]
blackbeard's infamous cutlass
[Music]
among the most notorious pirates of the
18th century blackbeard terrorized
caribbean and atlantic merchant shipping
with his trademark cutlass in hand its
short but thick curved blade featured a
razor sharp edge that was ideal for
hacking and slashing during close
quarters combat while seizing small
vessels in his legendary battle with
captain robert maynard in 1718
blackbeard's cutlass broke maynard's
sword in half with a single blow
today blackbeard's menacing presence and
expert swordmanship can still be seen in
the video game assassin's creed iv black
flag
blade smith to test the lethality of
your cutlass i'm going to inflict lethal
wounds on these ballistic dummies
jason you are first you ready i sure
hope so doug let's do this
[Music]
all right jason you got a very big
handle here but at least it's got the
swells it's got an indexing to where i
hold on to it i can tell where the edge
is
the weight that you have in this weapon
is so light incense that i can wield it
even around here you've got the clavicle
into the ribs all the way through the
lungs
and definitely it will kill
all i ever wanted to hear made my day
seth you're up next you ready get some
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh all right seth your sword is forward
heavy without a balance coming back i
don't know the shoulder is going to hurt
more the dummies are mine but your
weapon sir will kill
thank you
assess the strength and durability of
your swords i'll be chopping through
these bones and then attacking that peg
leg now remember this test is not about
what your blades do to these targets
it's about what these targets can do to
your blades
jason you're up are you ready nope
[Music]
the balance of your weapon
is really nice
which is surprising because you've made
a two-handed cutlass
your blade
held up very well except for the one
little chip and it's not even chip to
roll
so it didn't blow out it's a good job
thank you dave
all right seth are you ready yes sir
all right seth
first up
this thing's a beast
it is probably a pound heavier than your
competitor's sword
your blade i mean i can run my finger to
inhale down this i can see a couple of
glinting spots but it really didn't take
any damage
[Music]
all right bladesmiths let's find out if
there's any edge left this is the rope
cut and pirate sail slash to test the
edge of your cutlass i will cut this
rope which will raise the sail and then
i will slash the sail
this is all about what your sword will
do to the sailing rope
jason you up first ready yes sir
[Music]
alrighty jason your edge cut through the
rope easily and cuts with every part
that the edge met on this pirate sail
overall sir your sword
will cut
awesome
seth how you feeling
feeling good let's go let's do this
[Music]
all right seth
what are the chances you find a very
dull spot on the first cut on the rope
but on the second cut he'd found another
spot that was sharp but on the sail
working a heavy sword like this affects
my cuts
jason seth the judges have tested your
weapons and they've made a final
decision
our new forged and fire champion is
[Music]
jason
congratulations you're the new forge and
fire champion
seth unfortunately your blade did not
make the cut please surrender your blade
[Music]
jason congratulations you are our new
forging fire champion and that's a title
that comes with a bundle of bullion
that's worth 10 grand how you feeling
right now
come on
that's incredible fortune fire champion
you